ja erst mal vielen dank für die
einladung zu diesem sehr interessanten
format jessica vielen dank für die
vorstellung auch vielen dank für die
bisherigen vorträge die ich rein
geschaut habe auftritt also konnte sehr
viel profitieren findet ein ganz
spannendes thema ich bin jetzt
vielleicht eher jemand der von seinem
fach herkommend sich ihr selten mit
diesem thema befasst historikerinnen
historiker
kulturwissenschaftlerin
kulturwissenschaftler sind da sicherlich
erstmal von ihrem jeweiligen fachbereich
uns besser dafür prädestiniert dennoch
hat mich dieses thema so gereizt
natürlich auch aufgrund von persönlichen
erfahrungen
ich habe es auch in dem interview mit
euch schon mal erzählt er sich da auch
in den 90ern also richtig mitgemacht hat
mit dieser ganzen entwicklung wo diese
ganzen sequels noch gar nicht existiert
haben sondern wo die sequels erst
begründet wurden durch originelle
wirklich originelle neue erfindungen von
spielen und aufgrund dieser erfahrungen
auch philosophischen interessen mit dem
thema virtuelle realität thema
simulation
fiktion habe ich mich jetzt auch mal
gewagt in ein neues gebiet vorzudringen
und bin auch gespannt auf die diskussion
es geht also um game over respawn also
dieses thema gehört dann habe ich sofort
gedacht das ist doch ein philosophisches
thema das möchte ich mir mal jetzt hier
anschauen also überleben geht es um tod
des prüft jetzt auch ein bisschen einem
vorherigen vortrag an in computerspielen
ist eine philosophische betrachtung sein
ich hoffe es bringt ein paar neue
aspekte rein ich habe ein paar fragen
die sind immer jetzt aus philosophischer
perspektive zu verstehen was ist
eigentlich ein computerspiel die
medienwissenschaftlerin und
medienwissenschaftler werden da eine
ganz klare auffassung davon haben sie
werden sagen ist ein medium ein
digitales medium ein neues medium ich
will es versuchen aus einer
philosophischen perspektive auch ein
bisschen provokativ zu behandeln dann
was bedeutet es eigentlich computer zu
spielen also was für eine handlung
vollziehen wir da eigentlich dann wie
existieren wir den computerspielen und
beim computerspielen und
dafür natürlich abhängig wie überleben
wir im computerspiel und beim
computerspielen und dann möchte ich wie
ich schon angekündigt habe ein paar
phänomene genauer behandelt auch anhand
von konkreten beispielen
savegames auto saves und speicherpunkte
das sind interessante phänomene nicht
nur technologische phänomene auch
technologische phänomene aber auch
kulturelle phänomene und vielleicht
sogar philosophische phänomene die die
frage nach dem überleben im
computerspielen betreffen dann so was
wir leben oder lebensbalken
lebensenergie und extra leben
wiederbelebung und respawn das immer
beim thema dieser konferenz
schied finde ich auch total spannend und
natürlich wie der titel meines vortrags
lautet game over und ich möchte es
anhand von zwei beispielen
demonstrieren einmal wolfenstein 3d was
jetzt nicht mehr indiziert ist und
ruckelt legacy was ist kürzlich auch
kostenlos gab bei epic games also diese
zwei spiele sollte als vorbilder im
zentrum stehen und jetzt möchte ich
gleich mal ein bezug herstellen zu einem
sehr interessanten artikel auf spiegel
online spiegel netzwelt von fabian maus
hat aus dem jahr 2015 der sich genau mit
diesem thema auseinandersetzen den ich
sehr empfehlen kann sterben in spielen
und
der hier sehr sehr anschaulich die
neuere entwicklung dieses phänomens des
gamers und auch die veränderung dieses
phänomens in seinem artikel darstellt
kann ich sehr empfehlen ich bin ziemlich
auch immer wieder ein paar stellen
außerdem gibt es natürlich auch auf
wikipedia informationen hier ist leider
wie man sieht der artikel noch
verbesserungswürdig und ich selbst werde
da jetzt nach diesem vortrag und nach
der diskussion auch noch weiter daran
arbeiten kann aber auch allen die hier
zuschauen empfehlen jedoch ein bisschen
mitzuarbeiten dass diese artikel noch
ein bisschen mehr substanz bekommt ja
was ist eigentlich ein computerspiel ist
die frage in computerspielen besitzen
eine philosophische these in
computerspielen spielen wir nicht
einfach nur mit anderen sei es computer
gegner oder andere personen im internet
sind wir spielen auch mit uns selbst und
wir spielen mit möglichkeit und
wirklichkeit was heißt das dass wir mit
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit spielen
hier ist natürlich das stichwort
simulation fiktion und virtuelle
realität
ich möchte vor allem den begriff der
fiktion er stark machen also im
computerspiel können wir realitäten
welten handlungen auf eine ganz neue art
und weise nicht nur denken oder
darstellen sondern eben auch vollziehen
im virtuellen raum des computerspiels
alle computerspiele sind für mich
eigentlich ein virtueller raum ein
großer virtueller spiel kasten oder eine
sandbox wie man es will und deswegen
sind computerspiele auch eine besondere
form von wirklichkeit bezogen ich möchte
mich hier wirklich gegen diese häufig
anzutreffenden thesen wänden wonach
computerspiele eine form von
wirklichkeit entzug oder wirklichkeit
flucht sind nein kommt wieder spiele
sind immer eine form von wirklichkeit
bezog auch in wirklichkeit entzug es in
wirklichkeit bezug also möchte wirklich
computerspiele stark machen sie ernst zu
nehmen ich gehe sogar so weit zu sagen
computerspiele sind eine form von
bildung da möchte ich noch auf das
interview in weißen mit behind des
queens da haben wir darauf war auch
gesprochen sie sind glaube eine form von
bildung wenn man sie als wirklichkeit
bezug verstehen computer zu spielen da
lehne ich mir zu weit aus dem fenster
computerspielen bedeutet so würde ich
jetzt mal heute sagen auch zu
philosophieren wenn wir es als eine form
von wirklichkeit bezug und wirklichkeit
zur reflexion verstehen ich möchte ein
beispiel geben so was wie personale
identität es ist ein riesen themen der
philosophie das betrifft die frage was
macht unsere existenz im grunde
eigentlich aus wann hört unsere existenz
auf was sind wir im grunde solche fragen
kann man sehr gut im medium des
computerspiels nicht nur reflektieren
theoretisch sind eben auch praktizieren
das auch ganz wichtig das spiel erlaubt
uns nicht nur eine abstrakte reflexion
immer ganz konkret auch was zu tun im
virtuellen raum ja wie existieren wir
jetzt beim und im computerspielen wir
sind natürlich körperlich
nicht im computerspiel existent also wir
haben hier ein anderes eine andere form
von existenz die jetzt nicht körperlich
ist dann eben virtuell wie existieren
auch nicht unbedingt als die person
deren name in unserem personalausweis
steht und auch nicht mit diesem aussehen
und diesen eigenschaften wie zum
beispiel personalausweis stehen unsere
augen farben unsere größe gewicht steht
glaube ich nicht im personalausweis das
heißt wir können unsere eigenschaften
die wir natürlicherweise haben fiktiv
revidieren fiktiv ergänzen fiktiv
modifizieren oder völlig uns natürlich
neue virtuelle eigenschaften fiktive
eigenschaften geben entweder können wir
diese eigenschaften ganz frei wählen
auch die person die wir sein wollen
durch avatar
entfernte sie spielen ist es üblich oder
wir existieren in einem vorgegebenen
rahmen zum beispiel die wir eine fest
vorgeschriebene rolle einer anderen
fiktiven person einnehmen zb im spiel
wolfenstein dann nehmen wir einfach
diese rolle mit diesem blaszkiewitz ein
und haben dann nicht viel was wir zu tun
haben die können natürlich wenn wir die
rolle einnehmen uns individuell
verhalten aber diese ganzen
rahmenbedingungen wie wir aussehen was
von außen davon waffen uns gegeben ist
das ist vorgegeben das heißt die
existenzform in computerspielen kann
ganz verschiedene ich aussehen wie kann
sich sogar auf mehrere personen oder
figuren verteilen unsere existenz zum
beispiel wenn wir ganz verschiedene
personen oder figuren
steuern oder in sie hineinschlüpfen
können also strategiespiele sind hier
ein beispiel ich finde hier besonders
gut dungeon keeper wo wir sogar die
perspektiven wechseln können wir können
dungeon keeper in unsere figuren hinein
zoomen richtig hinein schlüpfen und sie
aus unserer perspektive aus der 3d
perspektive spiel wir können sie aber
auch aus der 12 börsen perspektive oder
sogar von so einer übergeordneten
perspektive
spielen das ist ganz dynamisch diese
existenz reisen hier könnte man noch
ganz viele andere formen angeben 2d
scola
überhaupt spiele wo gar keine form von
personalität enthalten ist wie zum
beispiel beim urvater pong da fragt man
sich auch ja wo bin ich da eigentlich
bin ich dieses steuerungselement bin ich
der ball was bin ich eigentlich
also es hier gibt es ganz verschiedene
ausformen jetzt möchte die frage
aufwerfen wie überleben wir eigentlich
in computerspielen computerspiele haben
die tendenz
unseren virtuellen tod zu vermeiden oder
zumindest aufzuschieben und zu
modifizieren darauf hat auch dieser
spiegel -artikel sehr zu recht
hingewiesen ich möchte was daraus
vorlesen
digitale games bieten
vermeidungsstrategien das reicht von
respawn wirklich übersetzt wieder
erzeugung einer spontanen wiedergeburt
meistens in multiplayer modus bis zum
zurückversetzen an den letzten
checkpoint das frustrierende game over
ist einem gleich gehts weiter gewinner
der tod ist nur noch eine kleine hürde
die möglichst wenig frustration
aufkommen lassen in diesem artikel wird
auch sehr gut beschrieben wie anfänglich
als die ersten computerspiele aufkam
dieses game aber wirklich definitiv
waren wenn man aus einem automat
gespielt hat das spiel dann musste man
neues geld reinschmeißen und wirklich
noch mal von vorne beginnen das system
noch mal neu starten und hier wird in
diesem artikel sehr schön gezeigt dass
dieses
definitiven game over immer weiter
aufgeweicht wird also hier ist das
stichwort von perma des vom permanenten
definitiven tod zu virtuellen
wiedergeburt das ist eine ganz klare
tendenz das ist unser leben und tod
dynamisiert und flexibilisiert wird
durch die neueren computerspiele ja
jetzt möchte ich auf ein paar phänomen
hineingehen ich hab schon genannt wir
haben savegames autos saves und
speicherpunkte was ist mit dem was haben
sie von der funktion die erlaubnis
unsere virtuelle existenz abzusichern
sie reduzieren also gewissermaßen sind
die virtuelle fallhöhe
auf die wir herabsinken können wenn wir
in einem spiel stand bestimmte
errungenschaften
erzielt haben wie zum beispiel
gegenstände eingesammelt oder ein spiel
eben bis zu einem bestimmten punkt schon
durchlaufen haben dann
bauen die gewissermaßen einen doppelten
boden rein und ein sicherheitsnetz er
unter dass wir nicht mehr fallen können
also sie sichern unsere existenz
absicherung ist jedes spiel und sie
flexibilisieren natürlich auch die
virtuelle existenz weil sie sich auf
ganz neue dinge konzentrieren kann hier
möchte ich auch verweisen auf den
wikipedia-artikel der sehr interessant
die technischen grundlagen dieses
kulturellen phänomens der save games
daraus stellt also es war wirklich auch
erst mal eine ganz große technische
frage wie man speicherpunkte wirklich
technisch realisiert kann ich sehr
empfehlen möchte ich jetzt aber nicht
weiter darauf eingehen auf die
technischen fragen dann war ich sehr
spannend finde ist lebensbalken
lebensenergie oder auch leben als
zusätzliche eigenschaften die man
sammeln kann der lebensbalken und die
lebensenergie die machen den tod zu
einer quantitativen
angelegenheit hier sieht man auch wieder
die tendenz von pandev weg zu gehen und
dem definitiven tod aufzuweichen jetzt
nicht unbedingt durch eine wiedergeburt
sondern eben durch eine quantitative
darstellung unseres lebens also in unser
leben liegt hier auch in geraden vor
virtuellen geraden sie erlauben auch die
kontrolle über unsere virtuelles leben
denn sie lassen sich immer wieder
auffüllen und aufladen also wir kümmern
uns um unser virtuelles lebens selbst
den wir in der virtuellen bild schauen
wie wir unser leben verlängern können
wieder auffrischen können wir uns heilen
können und natürlich auch heilen lassen
können von anderen virtuellen
personen das heißt extra leben die es
auch noch gibt sind virtuelle lebens
guthaben so kann man sich das auch
vorstellen dass natürlich auch ganz klar
auf dieser schiene weg von diesem
projekt zu kommen hier habe ich mir ein
schönes bild eines typischen lebens
balkens der jetzt hier sicherlich auch
gewandelt ist also man sieht hilfen
rechts unten dass es nur dann geht es
immer so graduell weiter manchmal sind
die wirklich ganz fallen graduiert
manchmal sind die immer so vier
abschnitten viele einheiten da gibt es
verschiedene formen dieses lebensbalken
es auch ein ganz spannendes thema nur
über lebensbalken sich im vortrag zu
überlegen dann wiederbelebung und
respawn
das sind jetzt spannende phänomene weil
sie das prinzip des game over dieses
paradies wirklich
aufheben und ganz neu denken lassen
damit dynamisieren wir unsere virtuelle
existenz aber nicht nur unsere
existenzen eben auch die existenz
anderer gegenstände im spiel zum
beispiel pick ups bei quake 3 arena oder
bei anderen spielen sondern x factory
nada respawnen auch gegenstände wie
waffen munition
gesundheit oder rüstung also diese
phänomene dass ich immer wieder neu
regenerierenden herstellende finden wir
auch bei anderen gegenständen nicht nur
bei uns haben sie ihre möglichen
virtuelle interaktion das ist ganz
wichtig und wir haben natürlich auch
noch schied das ist auch ein sehr
spannendes phänomen weil das wiederum
unser virtuelles leben auf eine ganz
grundsätzliche weise angehen lässt sie
überwinden das prinzip von game over auf
eine ganz individualisierte weise sie
erlauben es uns nämlich lebensenergie
leben spezielle eigen schafft und
gegenstände ganz individuell und ganz
spezifisch zu
bestimmen das heißt wir können am ende
sogar das spiel selbst durch die cheats
modifizieren ich möchte hier noch daran
erinnern an so was wie der clip wo man
also wirklich durch die spiel grenzen
hindurch läuft und so eine ganz neue
perspektive auf das spiel bekommt das
heißt hier wird nicht nur unser leben
modifiziert sind die lebenswelt
überhaupt der rahmen in dem wir
existieren durch schießt ist natürlich
ein ganz tiefer eingriff und hier habe
ich nur ein paar beispiele von duke
nukem 3d
die enns darf da kriegt man eben alle
gegenstände die es da bekommt man alle
schlüssel das geht aber natürlich noch
weiter in ganz verschiedene andere
bereich da kann man dann die perspektive
wechseln da kann man eine dritte person
perspektive einem und soweit es gibt
natürlich andere und sterblichkeit modus
der natürlich für das thema überleben
ganz zentral ist also hier spielt man am
ende mit dem spiel selbst game over
titel des vortrags sie stellen das
definitiven ende eines spiels da so dass
es neue begonnen werden muss das also
wirklich der harte tod der harte
virtuelle tod und diese games kann auf
ganz verschiedene art und weise
inszeniert werden hier möchte ich nur
ein beispiel geben von freizeit 13
1989 quelle ist auch diese artikel den
ich genannt habe aus dem spiegel ganz
einfach schwarzer hintergrund weiße
schrift die ranger fans update game over
fast einfacher geht es nicht mal könnte
es noch gut vorstellen dass einfach nur
weiß game over auf schwarzem grund steht
das ist sozusagen der prototyp des
gamers ist einfach schluss man sieht gar
nicht mehr jetzt möchte ich noch
abschließen ein paar beispiele geben
wolfenstein 3d
hier sieht man einen an die 3d
perspektive aus der ich perspektive
und ich möchte ich auf zwei dinge
hinweisen hier wird jetzt der tod auf
ganz verschiedene weise grafisch
dargestellt zum einen haben wir hier
auch eine perspektive hier unten auf uns
selbst also wir haben hier gewissermaßen
zwei perspektiven wir haben die erleben
die ich perspektive und die außensicht
und diese klar dieses kleine bild hier
unten zeigt einfach ein gesicht was
völlig nach dem tod ist oder eigentlich
genau am tod ist weil wir hier
prozentual auch noch eine quantitative
übersicht über unsere lebensenergie
haben die ist hier eben in prozent bei
wolfenstein 3d aber wir haben hier
immerhin noch zwei leben also so hart
ist jetzt dieses game over here nicht
und ich möchte noch auf was hinweisen
auf diese leichte rote tönung die man
hier vielleicht erkennen kann in diesem
spiel wenn man jetzt diese sequenzen ein
bisschen weitergehen würde würde man
sehen dass der ganze bildschirm rot
anläuft und rot zu läuft also hier wird
wirklich auch dieses dieser tod durch
die farbe rot wie das blut eben sehr
anschaulich dargestellt also dass das
game over manifestiert sich in diesen
bildern auf ganz verschiedenen ebenen
könnte man sagen als erste
ich-perspektive grafisch symbolisch wie
das rot wie das blut aber natürlich auch
hier prozentual oder mathematischen
genauer gesagt und noch hier aus der
außensicht total spannend diese
darstellung diese reflexion des todes
und abschließend noch wohl dass sie von
dem ich schon gesprochen hatte dass es
kostenlos kürzlich gab das ist jetzt
insofern ein sehr spannendes phänomen
weil es jedes game over noch einmal auf
eine ganz neue weise denkt weil es game
over nicht nur bezieht auf eine
spielfigur oder eine ebene sondern über
den tod hinaus denken lässt jetzt aber
eben durch die evolutionäre weitergabe
von nebenan weitere spielfiguren also
hier ist das evolution sprints ihp
angedacht was den tod auch irgendwie
überwinden kann den virtuellen spieler
tod das heißt hiermit wird die idee der
fortexistenz
durch neue generation konsequent gedacht
das heißt man kann sich dann auch über
verschiedene generationen verbessern es
gibt aber auch verschiedene eigenheiten
die diese neuen generation bringen ich
glaube etwas wie farbenblindheit oder
hyperaktivität oder sind diese ganzen
eigenschaften die man da weitergeben
kann die zeigen sich auch dann auf der
darstellung es gebe also das eben dann
auch der ganze spielmechanik sich
entsprechend dieser eigenschaften
verändert das finde ich eines der
interessantesten phänomene rolltreppe
sie über den tod auf mediale weise des
computerspiels zu reflektieren das halt
ich fast für eine kleine mediale
philosophie des todes ja hier ist noch
dieses bild es gibt mittlerweile legacy
2 ist kürzlich erschienen
das bild habe ich aus wikipedia genommen
ja dann bedanke mich jemals für die
aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf die
diskussion